to otago vilo he had his first start
yesterday the outcome went well the
process for the offense may not have
here's two after the game talking about
his first nfl start
i don't think i played to the standard
of what this offense is capable of
you know there were
there were certain plays where
you know i could have stepped up and and
made the right throw made the right
decision
but
i've heard heard it many times from the
guys in the locker room um you know it's
it's good that we still came out with
the win um
and aside from that
you know
thank god we got a good defense
well and the defense wasn't just good on
sunday it was spectacular it was one of
those rare days and when you get
touchdowns in the return game when you
flip the field with your defense
creating havoc and chris you were
talking about it yesterday brian flores
the head coach had to have seen
something in the rams protection that
they exploited repeatedly they made the
rams look
uh bad even though the rams ended up
grossly out gaining it was the biggest
margin of the year
from yardage
from one team to another regardless of
outcome the the biggest margin the
biggest difference and the rams still
lost the game it was you know
it was that speaks to the butt whooping
though it was on one side of the ball so
yeah those yards are there for the rams
and all that
but not in the competitive part of the
football game you know again that's
what's annoying about stats and things
like that you know people walk away at
the end of the year and go back and look
at this game and go whoa l.a 470 they
they were okay offense wasn't the
problem no the offense was the only
problem they were the biggest problem i
mean they gave the ball four four times
to miami one of them was a strip sack
fumble you know another one set up short
field so they're you know another one
took away points from themselves as far
as the rams are concerned brian flores
exposed sean mcvay in some of the things
that they like to do there's no doubt
about that yeah see the protections
having knowledge of where goff wanted to
go with the ball when he was hot and a
few times or i don't even know if i want
to say mcveigh got exposed or more of
like the plays i showed last night on on
football night in america mike where
there's just no way jared goff couldn't
have known
like hey they have us outnumbered and he
didn't like realize there was an extra
guy three out of the four turnovers
yesterday where that to me was like
shocking for a guy at this point of his
career to get hit like that like oh wow
i'm a rookie i didn't expect that guy to
be free
uh that was a little concerning about
the rams overall
it is jarring though to look at the
difference 31 first downs for the rams
eight for dinosaurs i know 471 total net
yards for the rams
145
for the dolphins and the dolphins win
the game 28 to 17 but that's what
happens when you can generate points
through your defense through your
special teams and when you can create
havoc
when the game is still undecided i know
they had to get a little nervous there
as the rams were starting to rack up
points but the dolphins put them away
early and then
held on mike that game go ahead i was
just saying there's three teams we've
talked about today and they're all real
good teams in football and they all have
somewhat of the same problem where you
go baltimore the 49ers and the rams i
look at them and go
they're good football teams
but when they can't bully you with the
run game
can their drop can their pass games win
them games can their drop back pass game
win them a football game
and i don't know i'm not sure you know
goth and garoppolo are a problem that
way you know lamar and that team aren't
set up that way
and i just i think those are big
questions about three playoff teams we
got going forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports